kevin hart top shot tyler the creator
crypto
people pringles pringles
hey everybody it's garyvee and welcome
to another episode of
overrated underrated with me garyvee
tyler the creator i think tyler the
creator is underrated i've always
thought he was
one of the most creative uh people in
the game
um i think he's a visually
exciting artist and i think that's cool
bang
energy drink bang energy drinks are
overrated
for me you know i've never enjoyed the
two that i've had
they did a lot of very viral marketing
with early influencers models
uh fitness people on instagram so i
really appreciate the way they
um marketed to build their way but i
definitely am going with overrated
because i've decided that context i'm
taking it is the actual beverage
nba top shot nba top shot is
nba top shot is um overrated
in the individual nfts like the
individual cards
and it's underrated as a project it's
insane what rohan and that team did to
launch that product
flow the consumer ability the
gamification
just an underrated execution like one of
one of the things we'll look back on is
one of the early things kind of like an
a like a yahoo or ask jeez or google or
youtube like
epic overrated are the individual top
shots because it's like cards there's
too much
supply demand issues coming as the nfl
mlb
ufc boxing muhammad ali pele like
everything in the world is going to be
nft
so right now a lot of the energy of
sports and nft
go to this one project like there's
gonna be people held with the bag on a
highlight of terry rozier making a pass
or like a solid dunk
by jaron jackson jr like this is not
like
other other ip this is not superman and
batman like the player matters
learning a new love language learning a
new what i need a new language
wow wow you're in love learning a little
did you learn a new love language
right um learning a new language
is overrated we have pods coming that
are going to do translation
plus i was terrible i got f's in spanish
and german consistently through my
entire career
so i don't [ __ ] with learning new
languages heavy metal
heavy metal is for me properly rated
because i actually think heavy metal is
underrated because i don't think it's
really that rated
like it's [ __ ] super niche at this
point big shout out to caleb
kevin hart kevin hart's super underrated
like grinded his [ __ ] way to becoming
one of the biggest movie stars and
entertainers in the world
[ __ ] stupid stupid underrated
kevin hart underrated the mona lisa the
mona lisa is overrated
i subjectively do not find that painting
super interesting at all
art is in the eye of the beholder and uh
i think like a squirtle pokemon card is
cooler
than a mona lisa pringles pringles
i like pringles i [ __ ] with pringles i
eat pringles
pringles are underrated owning a website
owning a website is overrated it's what
you do with the website that matters
it's like being an influencer it's like
having an nft project
what you do with it is what matters just
having it
means [ __ ] beards beards
i think they're properly rated at this
point right like there was like
it wasn't a thing during like friends
like the 90s right
everyone was clean-shaven then it became
super hipster like 2005
6789 i think it's settled into properly
rated at this why at this point i don't
think it's like a passion one way or the
other
making your bed in the morning the most
i don't think i've ever made my bed in
the morning in my entire life making
your bed in the morning
is wildly wildly overrated you just go
right back into it
wait you like making your bed no you
can't go right you just go right back
into it that's just a waste of [ __ ]
time
i think some people enjoy like it being
fresh
overrated pretzels
soft pretzels or like pretzels in a bag
i think
the overall genre of pretzel i'm gonna
go with
overrated even though i think soft
pretzels are underrated significantly
i just think bagged pretzels are so
overrated
except those big ones like the golden i
don't know you know like that
it's like the middle one the normal ones
which is the majority of the industry
austrian wine austrian this
history i-s-t-r-i-a-n-1
um indian wine producing the region of
israel yeah yeah i
literally know of it have never dug into
it
i have no answer for that which i love
by the way a wine question
sometimes right i just love the
authenticity of the show what
orange orange juice uh fresh squeezed
underrated
regular ridiculously overrated
there's a lot of context here yeah okay
i've had to break down multiple things
three of things now i've broken into
categories which is unusual
you know normally they're normally on
narrower topics
now we're talking topics you know what
real quick hold on this macro micro
thing
sending a text two one two nine three
one five seven
three one two one two nine three one
five seven three one
hold on real quick
make sure you always break
down things in the micro
and the macro don't
lend the two
words of encouragement credit cards
credit cards are overrated at this point
i'm swiping my phone the whole time
it makes my wallet feel heavier
overrated
abbreviations abbreviations
i think are underrated i love it i
abbreviate everyone's names
and things that make sure i like a good
abbreviation underrated popcorn
popcorn is underrated especially if it
has yeast
do you know what you know like the yeast
and popcorn [ __ ] with that pickled food
i'm russian like pickled foods are
stupid underrated
i love i i'm a pickled what is this uh
a pepper no
okra or whatever yeah okay i literally
have a pickled okra right here
underrated [ __ ] crypto pups
underrated that's all i'll say about
that horror movie
i don't [ __ ] with our movies um
so for me as like a fan of consuming
overrated
but i really like the genre the
creativity
so i'm gonna go with underrated me
because i'm just looking at it from that
angle
me i'm not a consumer of like i did a
little friday the 13th a little
you know you know elm street
there's been the modern place the blum
thing like but bloom studios but um
underrated candidate cam newton's very
underrated
i really like this guy you know i'm
super happy he's not a
is he not a patriot i think is it cut
i gotta but like i was dead that he went
to the pats because i
really love cam i think you know i
what's great about being
in the business is i have a good sense
of like
who he is as a human i'm a big cam fan
i'm a big fan cam newton is a massively
underrated human
creative [ __ ] good dude underrated
people people underrated he will go down
as an iconic nft artist part of that
first wave
he'll be like the tom of myspace you
know like
in like like in the internet culture
like just so associated with something
and has really he's a young man still
has a huge potential to become
an iconic world artist question of the
day
you have a question of the day yeah what
says a little off speed pitch
at the end though we do okay yeah
what what rihanni tv show would you want
to go on
survivor because i'd win
that is our show thanks for watching
actually you know what i'm gonna take
questions from my community 212-931-5731
text me with what i should put on next
week's overrated underrated
when you text me put hashtag overrated
uh
overrated put hashtag oh you oh you
text me two one two nine three one five
seven three one two
and what say pineapple and then space
hashtag
oh you will be easy for me to find i
will see you next week's
overrated undefeated youtube watcher
what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to
explode stories polls more content more
engagement more surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you